taller than a six-story building
longer than three school buses
ten times as heavy as an elephant
the largest dinosaur ever is coming back
from extinction
what would life be like walking among
these giants
how could we possibly tame these
creatures
and
how would they threaten to destroy human
society
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the argentinosaurus
was alive today
in 1987
a farmer in southwestern argentina made
a discovery that shook the paleontology
world to the bones
six bones to be more precise
and they seemed to come from the largest
dinosaur to have ever existed
argentinosaurus or argentine lizard
lived during the middle cretaceous
period about 90 million years ago
they were herbivorous sauropods
that means that they subsisted on a diet
of plants and their bodies had
distinctly long massive necks and tails
and when i say massive
i mean massive
though they'd start their lives as small
as 5 kilograms
over 40 years they would grow to be
around 75
000 kilograms
at the peak of their growth they could
have gained around 40 kilograms every
day
that means these dinos likely had a
never-ending appetite that required 100
000 calories daily
so if they were alive today
would they eventually eat every plant
and crop on the planet
if the argentinosaurus managed to stage
a comeback
they'd discover that their old stomping
grounds in south america
would look very different than they did
so many millions of years ago
the ecosystems that exist in this part
of the world are completely different
than they were then
this would pose a problem for the
voracious leafy appetite that the
argentinosaurus had
and they wouldn't be the only ones with
an ecosystem headache
you would too
they would eat so many of our trees that
they could completely alter the world as
we know it
along with their eating habits these
creatures would bring chaos and
destruction everywhere they went
paleontologists suggest that these
dinosaurs were a towering 17 meters tall
and spanned 35 meters in length
which is a size that continues to baffle
scientists
who wonder how the creatures could have
managed to hold up their own giant necks
it's estimated that their hearts would
have needed to be able to pump blood as
far as 12 meters about 50 to 60 times
every minute
combine their stature with their
astounding weight and they destroyed
just about everything in their path
homes infrastructure people
it would be kind of like godzilla only
more by accident
especially if there were more than one
argentinosaurus
and you better believe there would be
with these dinosaurs roaming around you
could expect to come across one of their
nesting sites on your next hike
argentinosaurus was an egg-laying
species and females could have laid
anywhere from 10 to 15 eggs at a time
and these wouldn't be anything like your
average chicken eggs
they'd be as large as 30 centimeters in
diameter
it's likely that you'd need to come up
with some ways to contain their growing
population size
soon enough they could lay so many eggs
that all of south america would be
overrun by big dinos
if only there were a way that we could
tame them like elephants and use them to
our advantage
but this would be a pretty dangerous
task considering their size
and not to mention our lack of knowledge
about how temperamental they could have
been
besides the conditions we'd need to keep
them in would likely be inhumane
it would involve keeping them in
contained areas that aren't large enough
to sustain them
but of course we couldn't let them
wildly roam the planet wherever they
wanted
i mean that is if you wanted to keep
living on this planet too
you'd hopefully see conservation efforts
to provide an area for them to wander
about and live peacefully
though coming up with a system to
actually contain them
would be a tough task
electric fences could be effective as
the argentinosaurus lacked natural body
armor so they'd be vulnerable to shocks
or injuries
but if they gathered in herds as
paleontologists suggest they would then
even more space and kilometers of
electric fences could be necessary
but this would also help to protect them
from poachers
looking to hunt down the biggest game
known to man
it would especially protect the babies
who would be left to fend for themselves
as soon as they were born
sadly
reintroducing the largest dinosaurs to
ever exist
would ultimately lead to yet another
attempt by humans to conquer everything
in nature
so maybe we meet our match with a dino
that has a little more of a craving for
our tasty human flesh
like if the t-rex suddenly came back
from extinction
well
that's a story
for another
what if
[Music]